bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenute
questo video sono progetti sono con
gianpi e la gianpi si giampieri
preferisce sia giampiero non va
benissimo capito bene grazie
quando dico grazie ok allora oggi
proviamo a fare un giorno che avevo
fatto da solo che si chiama ivo dai data
l'avevo fatto col gatto se però si può
fare anche con conte sono sicuro che
riusciremo a trovare qualcosa di decente
a fare quel così le cento grazie prego
allora perché ti subito è perfetto così
l'obiettivo è arrivare di sopra quindi
devi girare il più possibile a me va
bene ma tant'è che c'è se non ci sono
prove che volendo io ti posso dare una
mano se non ci arrivi a ma cerca anche
prede abbiamo proprio ora che dopo
dovremo unire le forze per far le cose
l'inter è tranquillo io non mi calvo
molto tempo squadre di beccare le punte
che il carbone ha punito senza cagate
guarda guarda mi no no no però secondo
me non si può si può fare
anzi ha ragione scusa guarda lo script è
bravo sono grande ha solo chiesto
arrivando sta arrivando
non c'è nessun altro perché sono
diventato che colore è il tubo
incredibile ok noi ci mettiamo sentiva
una mano ci mette una vita e invece ti
prendo io a posto e devi salire la leva
liszt e la tv esce un palloncino
si è quindi gli attacchi a te lo ricordi
e quasi pre si preannuncia un livello
bello lungo la vacca contrattacchi hands
custer bellissimo io continuo a sinistra
davanti per il fascino di questa prova
ma guardatelo la donna però è schifoso
tutto tutto è schifato e vai tu puoi
fare così ammesso che l'obiettivo sia
questo effettivamente settimana scrive
dall'europa vai
roma non solo il pd sono morto però
partire a chiamare invito arriva puoi
far misto livello ha notato schifo e
quanto poteva scappare dai però pure
manco st sfiga è un ora l'uccello occhio
che si tenga d'occhio casinò preso e per
sky preso il chelsea
novell è una bruttissima ma noi comunque
non è molto temibile comunque sono
veramente molto ve lo consiglio
va bene nei ritardi non vedo a ok perché
c'è lei davanti che succede incrinò hai
capito non puoi farlo hai capito lo devi
colorare quel sangue cioè quelli che no
non puoi fare non puoi fare c'è una roba
lì capii subito alza a sinistra guarda
non si capisce niente anzi che riuscì a
niente tipo c'è morire aspettati rimilab
bilancio ok rai o bellissimo ho preso
qualcosa che non so niente
ok flash laccio inquadrata no devo
lanciare mentre tunisini la mano se non
l'hai slancio hai capito
tre ore vogliamo la data anche qui era
era un lunch credibili
adesso adesso bellissima trasmette
dovete io stesso che fuori dalla mappa
guarda che appena hd su subito subito di
lancio e vai
non ti lasciato subito adesso bravo vai
aspetto adesso quindi una leggera adesso
[Musica]
tocca a te io cosa di dire cose che ho
tirato il palloncino palloncino adesso
esce fuori
bravo fuori o trascinano proprio fuori
fuori poi manca poi un po e un po lento
guardami cioè non molla la riprendilo ma
mannaia ma che devo fare
ok forse da qui joystick sì sì sì sì sì
fossi un all in one only fondativa 42
ore ci abbia messo il primo a fare
quella che regola la maledizione madonna
rai abbiamo perso 80 anni ma lo stesso
nando
no ragazzi bastano questo un secondo no
perché cia non 86 barriere immagine di
lancio di lancio ma ci saranno 86 magari
vai bel bello aspetta che le 86 barriere
ecco le prime foto provinciale mai
salito a rompervi era successo
nasce un tot 96 capitalismo flusso di
emozioni ce l'hai
ok labirinto no proprio non mi chiedere
la giorni di tragedia ferra bravo e ci
sono è no d'altra parte no dall'altra
parte non ci voglio per agirà dietro
ecco mi prendi la chiamano così eccolo
eccolo premio ma è una specie di rombo
questo
e noi dietro è un rombo strano ok tanto
immaginavo ci fosse qualcosa che male
non ho ancora solo capi su ok ok
bisogna passare cioè c'è un ostacolo di
sopra che subito sorpassi sicuro ok ok
eccolo là ok ok vai vai non può anzi sta
prendendo nelle marche è una discesa
occhio realta
no no no no no no no usera to say no ok
a posto no però non so cosa sia successo
e no e al tranello attirato il
palloncino ma non so se serve eccovi
arrivo per la di sopra di sopra agate
aggrappati non va genova su ok
c'è una fisica un po strana vai fare
tutto il giro istante mi metto a
prepararti quindi ho preso anche la
grappa di suleiman mamma no comunque
dell'osso gioco credi sgurdo troppo
bello della prima di tutto senza la
immensa qualcosa siamo patate usa aveva
finito forse ottimi ricordi si sente le
patatine e le walls l ua così bravo da
una vita che non le mani pure io mi
facessero fare un placement sto
scherzando non erano legate no no se il
cantù stop
cos'è no no no cos'è ok non era
difficile
invece momento come signor bravo bravo
bravo ma lo faccio mai però mi metto qua
pure io ho dato bravissimo un altro giro
sì sì ci arrivo carico ma che cosa
arriva alla mia vita aggrappare allo
stremo per simpatia che si si si
ecco chi è che adesso ci riuscireste mai
così a melilla questa bellissima due
minuti meravigliosi ma tu quanti livelli
ci sono non lo sono giovani infinito
ragazzi
ringrazio il giampiero per essersi
suicidato molteplici volte spero che
vide vi sia piaciuto
fatemi sapere se volete altri episodi di
cibo
ringrazio gian primaria partecipato
visto video date al suo canistro in
descrizione e noi un bacino ci siamo
iscritti al canale mi piace la
campanella è molto importante lasciato
un commento su cosa ne pensate dei
nostri suicidi e non ci vediamo come
sempre hanno proseguito e ragazzi
[Musica]